please welcome tracy corset hi tracy
hi great idea thank you thank you
this is so brilliant thank you gave you
the inspiration to come up with the idea
yeah so i started my page um in 2019 i
was getting my phd
and i came to the city to do some
research and i stayed with a family who
it was a family of chefs and every night
they made these really delicious meals
and i asked them for tips and tricks and
they were like girl this is just from
trader joe's like it's not that not that
serious so i was like oh okay so i
wanted to try my hand at it because i
was obviously busy getting my phd and um
i made my page to show other busy people
that it's easy to make something
delicious from trader joe's ingredients
well we're going to focus on the food of
it all today and we've got uh uh we've
got a taste tester in our audience
joining us say hi to karen otero hi
karen
hi
hi
how are you
this outfit too thank you like i'm so
excited please tell us
about your first dish yes so the first
dish is a tater tot casserole so there's
tater tots they have um
their
their vegetable for some um
cheese ground beef and it's perfect for
the family it's also perfect if you're
having a potluck because it has a lot of
people this feeds a lot of people when
you show up to a potluck with this hot
dish you are the most popular person at
that potluck i'll tell you that what do
you think karen i love it it has a
little bit of everything in there my
kids would love it as a busy mom myself
um with three kids i think that they
would enjoy this what ages are your kids
okay so
28 22 and 17.
karen
where did you sell your soul
and what fountain of youth are you
drinking out
well i guess it's just being genetics
i'm puerto rican um i think it's
happiness even though i'm divorced you
know still looks okay that might be
adding to it that's it right there it's
time to start a singles club maybe yeah
where we're going
maybe i singles club and we're hosting a
turkey
i don't know if you've heard of this
very popular thing called the single
ladies turkey fry because we're doing it
i'm in you're in i'm in well i'm into
this okay what is our next dish
yes so the next dish is vegetarian it's
the uh vegetarian gyoza curry soup so i
have the frozen veggie
gyoza and then an awesome
thai curry sauce and so i had always
just been marinating meat or tofu with
it and i wanted to use it in a
interesting way so i did it in a curry
soup
smack you like a boom
and it's super simple it's only five
ingredients and um it's delicious so
wait this feels like a flavor bomb how
is it only five ingredients yeah it's
the curry sauce is really
delicious and so
yeah just i will add those tortillas in
here too oh yeah yeah you could use this
on these notice they take it away
we need those because they know me
um wow that really packs a punch it does
not taste like something out of the
frozen food section exactly or five
ingredients it feels like the entire
spice rack come to life mm-hmm yeah yeah
all right what's your next dish you're
gonna love this one so this next dish is
perfect for those who really just don't
want to cook at all um it's in the
frozen section and i know that you love
mac and cheese it's my favorite it's
their french onion mac and cheese i've
never tried it before
yep all right yeah let's talk about that
yum it's that swiss cheese on the top
right mm-hmm it tastes like french onion
soup and then that mac and cheese
texture
carve it down
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you really did you really empty that out
down there can't talk
[Laughter]
wow
this was so delicious i can't believe
all this is a trader joe's and this is
all in your book and this is all in my
book yes your book is so wonderful tracy
corson get her delicious recipes on
instagram at tracy joe's oh that's cute
and
thank you for bringing all of this
culinary love and also attainability you
know i'm i cook but i'm intimidated and
when i get stuff like this i feel so
empowered about incentivized that's okay
karen
single lady turkey fry i'm in
[Music]